[Musique]
louis-georges griffith bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidat au carbet vous avez
47 ans vous êtes cadre au ministère de
la justice
vous allez mener la liste pour le carbet
solidaire et ambitieux alors pourquoi
vous présentez pour ce que vous êtes
cons cient municipal de l'opposition
et c'est la deuxième fois que vous
présentez oui alors tout d'abord bonjour
aux auditrices et auditeurs de
martinique première il particulièrement
au carvi sienne et au cap haïtien qui
nous écoutent ce matin alors pourquoi je
me représente
tout d'abord laissez-moi vous dire que
je suis un quart des siens j'ai toujours
vécu au carbet j'ai grandi au carbet
j'aime le carbet je dis ça pour quoi
parce que pour exercer la fonction de
maire il faut trois conditions
nécessaires de base il faut aimer les
gens
il faut aimer sa commune et il faut
connaître sa commune mais ce n'est pas
suffisant donc je suis dans la
continuité d'un engagement politique
depuis l'âge de 19 ans auprès de la
population du carbet et d'un engagement
depuis 1995 au sein des conseils
municipaux
j'ai exercé les fonctions comme
président de commission comme des
fonctions de maire adjoint et permettez
moi de vous dire que font fort de cette
expérience ces boxeurs lattes en 2014 je
me suis présenté aux élections
municipales et nous sommes sortis
deuxièmes ce qui nous a permis par la
proportionnelle de siéger au sein du
conseil municipal
en tant que membre de l'opposition je
suis chef de groupe de l'opposition
et ben pourquoi je me représente je peux
vous dire que aujourd'hui le carbet est
invité le cab est habité par ce que le
maire actuel il faut le savoir a investi
que 7 euros par habitant le carbet
tellement arrêtez monsieur que nous
avons deux chantiers initiés depuis la
mandature de 2008
le concerne la culture c'est à dire une
médiathèque vous rendez compte depuis
les les jeunes sont privés de
médiathèque et l'autre concerne un
centre d'accueil donc le sport depuis
2008 ces chantiers sont invités et puis
je reviens aux élections municipales
parce que aujourd'hui le développement
économique du carbet est en panne
nous avons eu la fermeture du bar où bat
la fermeture d'aqualand nous avons la
fermeture de beaucoup d'anciennes et
puis qu'est ce qui me fait revenu encore
eh bien c'est la population les gens
abandonner des quartiers abandonnés nous
avons même un quartier qui a été d
éviter les calaisiens se demande est ce
qui là est ce que ce quartier appartient
encore au carbet ou à bellefontaine ms
mais la fermeture marouba d'aqualand pas
du fait du maire monsieur ce n'est pas
le fait du maire mais quand vous êtes
maire d'une commune vous intéresser à ce
qui se passe quand vous êtes maire d'une
commune
il faut savoir se lever de son siège de
ne pas s'arrêter à dire eh ben j'ai un
président de la ctm qui est contre moi
et donc mes travaux n'avancent pas on
pense au bâton de pèlerin on se lève de
son siège et on va s'intéresser à ce qui
se passe nous savons que le mas rouma a
été repris en compétences pour la ctm
il faut il faut oui est également
l'aqualand il faut quand on est maire
qu'on se lève de son siège pour prenne
son bâton de pèlerin et qu'on
s'intéresse un peu à ce qui se passe
mais le garder aussi dynamique on l'a vu
avec les restaurants alors des choses
qui ont été faites de ce nous alors ce
côté-là premièrement le carbet dynamique
qu'est ce que vous appelez carmes et
dynamique vous parlez aussi des fêtes
ont parlé des animations mais à qui
profite ces animations
monsieur c'est ça la question à qui
profite et animations je veux vous dire
à deux catégories de personnes à aux
organisateurs et aux mères du carbet et
à quelques élus jeudi quelques et du
pourquoi je dis ça
aujourd'hui vous avez des fêtes
oses-tu le car mais vous avez des
nuisances vous vous rendez compte
nous avons ils ont été obligés de monter
un collectif pour rappeler aux maires
ses obligations sous les nuisances
d'accord on va tout aborder parce qu'une
ouest 40 secondes
les grandes lignes de votre programme
alors un axe important 30 secondes pour
l'accès important de votre programme
alors la première chose c'est de
remettre le cap baissier au coeur de sa
ville le cas bastien a besoin de retour
de se retrouver au coeur de sa ville
deuxièmement c'est investir dans
l'humain c'est pour investir dans
l'humain monsieur c'est redonner du lien
social
sirois donnait du bien-être à la
population et puis il faut casser ce mur
de séparation entre les personnes âgées
la jeunesse les marins pêcheurs les
agricultures à qui on a promis monts et
merveilles et qu'on a rien fait voilà en
gros et puis dans tout ça dans tout ça
donc il faut réhabiliter l'existant et
construire un programme pour les quarts
des siens messieurs permettez moi de
vous dire et je tien minh dessus ça
s'appelle tout simplement travailler
autrement et c'est une volonté politique
louis-georges vite je vous remercie
merci à vous
[Musique]